I'm on a mission to test out the top
celeb chef cookery courses and tonight
I'm going after Delia
but first I'm off to Joe Christophe
novellas he's a big French bastard that
no one can really understand but he
really thinks he's a big hit with the
ladies in a a bit of a smoother so I'm
off to have some fun and to see what can
really get away with
I've known JC for years and used to work
alongside him there's gonna be a tall
order to get this one right
the Novelli Academy course costs 350
quid and is an intimate affair for up to
16 students for that price you get to
spend six hours of the heart the cheer
Academy and join demonstrations and
tastings with a nation's favorite French
chef I'm about to go in I'm absolutely
bricking myself now the experts say that
the first five minutes of respects are
the most dangerous time so I hope the
[ __ ] I don't get caught
Tim's it's not as I or James gets
acquainted with these fellow students
the man himself arrives and starts to
introduce himself to the group
this is this you saw and you see screams
[ __ ] I know they do it you stand I think
I know what you are should it you have
Gotham you are golden arms it for [ __ ]
sake are you doing here so annoying
really annoying I can't believe he's
following me so early for [ __ ]
release me
no at least let me get into the course a
little bit you should realize that I
would've split you so doing huh no I
didn't know you could [ __ ] sniff me
out like that yeah maybe after the
starter and I think because you smell as
a muscular just a little figured out
he's playing old and he's got legs like
a gladiator hey congratulations yeah I'm
ready
hey ribbon up with my big smile you know
you know damn damn damn damn I can't
believe he spotted a [ __ ] early so
I'll have to work a little bit harder
next time